du cinéma pour terminer cette édition
est la performance de l'actrice
américaine meryl streep performance
d'actrice dans la rivière sauvage qui
sortira mercredi mais aussi une vraie
performance physique elle a tenu à
tourner elle même les scènes de descente
en raft dans les rapides du montana
nicolas cornu langlois et maryse richa
que meryl streep pose devant les
photographes
qu'elle soit dans les rapides devant les
caméras ou en face d'une journaliste
elles montrent le même professionnalisme
le même enthousiasme la même passion
c'est une randonnée à travers ce lieu
tellement tellement surprenant et
parfois encore maintenant quand j'en
vois le film je m'agrippe à mon siège
et je m'accroche comme si j'étais sur
des montagnes russes
c'est une balade sportive familiale qui
tourne mal parce que le couple et
l'enfant vont être prises en otage par
des gangsters en fuite qui veulent être
conduit au delà des rapides
il menace de tuer l'enfant si elle
refuse de l'équipe et c'est aussi un
film sur l'amour d'une mère qui peut
faire des choses extraordinaires quand
son enfant est mené c'est une chose dont
on ne croyait pas capable
ces gens vont faire tous les jours et je
suis devenu accro à cette heure il m'est
arrivé d'avoir envie de sauter par
dessus bord alors ils criaient tous ne
saute pas la pire des choses à faire
les sauveteurs tout proches sont prêts à
intervenir
les conditions de travail sont
extrêmement difficiles car l'action a
toujours lieu sur le bateau et c'est une
performance
je me sentais parfaitement médaille
quand j'allais dormir le soir je tombais
sur l'oreille et l'on comprend vraiment
pourquoi